our 8 news now investigators the man
accused of killing his girlfriend's
four-year-old son and then keeping that
boy's body in a freezer going back and
forth with a judge today about who
should represent him this whole case is
built off the deception
um there was a perfect testimony where
we talk about it no I would like to
address this I would like to address
this right now if I may I have no
attorney
at this point
you not to talk right now I'm I'm okay I
will talk right now if I'm in
so our camera is the only ones in court
as 36 year old Brandon toastland asked
for a new public defender after ditching
his previous one he'll remain in jail
until his murder trial begins in October